we are going to start with the most
difficult thing in the entire semester
it's about how to pronounce my name okay
I can do please find the light switch
for this spotlight because it's a bit
partisan all right I got this okay this
one is okay so I am from Hungary and
this is pronounced as scar Jo a cow is
essentially the equivalent of cows in in
toys or chars in English John I love
this there's no children for that for so
I'm sorry so it is pronounced as cower
if you imagine this as like an English
word then you forget beheld and you just
pronounce it like that so it's calary
okay so I'd like to hear some examples
so Kerry Kerry
okay yes yes excellent a bit louder
how is it the answer yet so it's coming
so it's all it's like why I didn't start
one more time Oh water-powered
yes absolutely Wow
it's amazing okay now comes the hard
part so this is pronounced as July
okay so it's Hungarian is a weird
language where Z and s is actually one
letter so if you take a look at the
Hungarian alphabet there is a letter
that is Z there's a ladder that is s and
there's a third letter that is Z and s
together so it's pretty ridiculous isn't
it so this is pronounced as July so this
is the difficult part okay so my joy Wow
I can perhaps draw my yeah even a little
okay sure yes yes sure
Wow are you are you on your engine
opinion he has turns maybe secretly from
Jordan yeah Wow
it's not sure sure sure okay is there
someone who I have forgotten or everyone
everyone knows what's up okay so this is
what we're going to be doing so the
amazing thing is that when you see
images on the internet like that
sometimes it's difficult to find out if
this is if it is computer graphics or is
it a real photograph and this is one of
these examples this is another example
and this is the work of amazing
engineers and amazing artists and we are
going to be talking about how to compute
images like that and if you look at this
well when you download the slides at
home you will see that on the lens the
dust is modeled here you can see just
some small splotches but you can
actually see pieces of dust on the lens
of the camera and this is computed with
the computer program and by the end of
the semester you are going to know
everything about this how is this
exactly computed every single pixel just
a few things about organization there's
going to be assignments and they take up
40% of your grade and these assignments
will have most of them will have
theoretical parts and on paper
I'll go under how to understand what's
going on in nature and there will be
there will be also programming exercises
but they are not really that programming
X
sighs it's it's mostly using programs
understanding what they are doing and
maybe modifying them here and there but
you are not going to write a huge
rendering engines and things like that
so don't worry about this the 60% part
is world exam and this is going to take
place after the semester and with me so
this is some friendly discussion about
what you have learned or not so friendly
discussion if you haven't learned
anything but that's never okay so I'm
just kidding and this is going to take
place early but you can choose so if you
would like to have the exam with Thomas
that's also fine but I would like to
note that I am an engineer and he's a
brilliant physicist so if you choose you
know who to who to try to deal with I
would choose the engineer I I don't know
about you this is just just a suggestion
and there can be some kind of individual
contribution so if you find some errors
on the slides if you add some figures
that hey I don't like this figure I've
drawn something better than that there's
going to be problems that we work with
if you find some box in there or if you
can extend it in any way you can get
plus points and this applies to
basically any kind of contribution that
you have this is the book that we are
going to learn from so there is trying
to cover everything and at some point I
will say that yeah
please open the book
like to know more about this but
whatever I tell you here is going to be
enough for an exam so it's not going to
happen that hey why haven't you read I
don't know
H 859 don't you remember that that this
is not going to happen so this is to
augment your knowledge if you would like
to know more and this is a great place
to do and this has a website this can be
bought at different places there is some
sample chapters and before buying you
can take a look whether you like it
enough or not so it's pretty cool that
it has sample chapters let's start with
one you shouldn't expect from this
course I'll just run through it there's
not going to be rigorous derivation of
every imaginable equation that you have
so there are courses where there is this
this never-ending infinite loop like in
programming an infinite loop of
definition CRM corollary definition
theorem theorem lemma raise your hand if
you've been to a course like that I'm
not going to tell anyone okay so I'm not
going to heaven so I've had a lot of
these courses and I've had enough so so
I'm trying to do it differently there's
not going to be endless derivations
there's not going to be an under stream
of formulae as well without explanation
there's going to be formulaic
but with explanation we're going to play
with all of them and you are going to
understand that the core meaning of
these things and at the same time please
don't expect to understand everything if
you open for instance to max render
source code this is like a half a
million line of code project one of the
best lenders out there but there's many
there's many really good renders you
will not understand every single thing
that is there but you will understand
how the light transport part works as
thoroughly as possible
and the most important thing I've put it
there in bold because this is what
students love you don't have to memorize
any of the formulae okay so I never tell
you that okay give me this formula and
and you will have to remember it off the
back of your head I don't care I mean if
you're an engineer at the company you
sit down you need to solve a problem if
you don't remember something what do you
do Google and you look for it this is
it's not important to remember things
it's important to understand things so
if you look at the formula you will have
to understand what is going on
and that's intuition this is what I
would like you to have as much as
possible but you don't need to memorize
any of these now what you should expect
from this course is how to simulate
light in a simple and elegant way this
is going to be a surprise at first
because things are going to look
complicated and by the end we're going
to derive really simple solutions for
that that can be implemented in 200
lines of C++ so this 200 lines can
compute something that's almost as
beautiful as what you have seen here and
I have written this piece of code and
every theorem that we learn about you
are going to see them in code in fact
there's going to be an entire lecture on
a code review right let's go through
this regular and and see there is slicks
approximation there is smells law there
is this and that and every single thing
that you learn here you are going to see
in code it's not just flying out in the
window you will know why nature looks
like as it does in real life and you
will be wondering that there's there's
so many beautiful things and why haven't
I seen them the way they are why are
they
the way they are and you will know about
also most of the state-of-the-art in
global illumination this means that yes
we will start with algorithms from 1968
and we will end with algorithms from
this year like from two weeks ago or in
the next few weeks because the sea graph
is coming like to see graph paper is the
biggest conference with the desktop the
bunch is coming in the next few weeks
and I'm going to read through it and the
materials will be updated to the very
latest works and another thing is that
really important is that you will be
able to visualize and understand
complicated formula in a really
intuitive way so I would like you to
learn something that's not only like
transport specific but you will be able
to use this knowledge wherever you go
whatever kind of mathematical problems
you have this knowledge will be useful
and we will see from the very first
lecture and the most important thing is
that you will see the world differently
that is there is lots of beautiful
things in nature and you won't be able
to stop looking at it so you will you
will perhaps like taking the train or
public transport a bit more than before
because there's there's so many
intricate delicate things to see that
you haven't seen before we have looked
but you haven't seen them before